in this capsule we see an example
running the flu to the star
step by step
then the example we will use is
a simplified example we have to find the
shortest way between two cities
so in this case we have a very good example
it's just six cities
on our map
we have a departure city and heroes
our destination city your m6 la
distance is where the blow is on the
arcs var actually corresponds to the distance
real between these cities there and notoriety
we're going to use here it's going to be a
distance as the crow flies on since it is
not the graphics does not really say the
true distance as the crow flies so in
do you just have to do
trust that it's rustic
when she gives out it's beautiful and
well the distance as the crow flies to other
for example in this case the city n 0
and the city m6 or in this case also the
distance as the crow flies between the city
m1 and the destination city so this
would be ok so the figure I skip
above do not match him ristic
and the number associated with arcs
corresponds to the actual distance between
two adjacent cities so let's see
step by step execution
so what do you think I'm going
give on each line it's actually the
configuration of the variable open and
of the closed variable at the beginning of each
iteration of the loop in time to
star specifically to be more
accurate in open and enclosure what are we going
to have it's not just 9th of May in
more than one or state so here you have
same things as we see also
the value of f for this summer there so the
fdn associated with the state and we will have
also point to the parent who has
generated as a child
the nude in question ok so at the very beginning
stars insert the initial name 1 0
in open with additionally its value of f
so the value of f here since the
rustic is equal to 9 and then I have
hate in that it would be zero
since the distance between 0 and 1 0 and 2
the value of f maybe of neef then
to point to the godfather but
since no point release
next what are we going to have done a
iteration is to add the children of 1
to 0 so the successors of 1.0
then 3rd of n1 and noticed that in
open here we will have put the draws in
ascending order of the horror of f
so for the nil n 1 actually his
fc value the cost of these 30 from n 1 to
know 3 plus the rustic which is two
so 5 also
so 5 that's right here actually the
calculation for the other two for nde
actually you are going to get 4 + 2
so six reindeer husband 3-2 +5 so having
after that we also put our
we agree to treat the initial name
in claude then of that we will take
May 1 of the list at open cm1 so
we are made to treat that here and then we
will add her naked breasts line
successor in open to know 25 and one
go when we insert it in open on
wants to insert it in the order of its value
of f2m its value of f1 fota in this
case 3 + 7 more so that's the
value of jdm game dance regales to 10 plus
logistics 2 so we should have a
Nil to 12 for n 5
if we finally introduce them
inserting so as to maintain order one
is going to have 25 and perfect last
the open list and finally we will put
it is not appropriate to treat namely 1
will insert it in closer the clause of
no need to keep in order
growing f
club interiors and we continue
we are now made to treat the
knot haendel so we must in that
it's added his child who m 4 n 4
is that they have justice there is
associated a value of f which is 4
more than +3 so the path that goes through
haendel in what it's probably the
generic in four it would be 4 + 2 so
6 for j2m and three plus three for the
ristic so new and inserting it
now the order
it happens to be placed second
then she will have to and added as
usually the neutral and and add
of next station pens we take the
first in open again which n
3 and we generate his children because
if we have two we've had two more
times and a cape
again so if we consider a
n 2 series then hard for the way
which goes through m3 to actually have a cost of
1 f so of the two plus a gift jdng of
haendel in this case for this way there
indulge in you + logistics dn2 to
know two airlock had a total value
of 5 and note that in close
we had already m2 however its value of
facts was greater
so that's going to allow us to when
even the agitated in opel ok otherwise we
could not he then added two
only other children cm 4 and 24 in this
case also for a path that goes through
m3 the value of j2m case for this path
there it would be + 1 and we will adjust its the
restic that would be 3 so would we have
would have a value of f that would be six
now notice that n 4 was already
in open but again because
n 4 who was already in the country of avesnes
f value larger than the node
generated via another path the new
frame generim from our paths
in this case we will replace m49 ender
by m 4.6 m3 ok so we removed
a map and then we added instead
so we saw we removed this part
there here this tripled at the 24 and then we go
add that there instead and notice
also that we did the same thing
for m 2 it was removed from Klose on
no need to be there since we
has a triple duplicate partners in ok
I will remove lancre to do a little
of space by iterations next
so we have to add the child
of n2 in that so if only one
child who loves 4 when these in
this case the path that goes through
haendel and by m3 so it's like this
that since 1 2 by his parents 3 and n 4
by the way that wants am4 passed in this
case by m2 we have a way I have to
hate associated with a plus-by-two + 1 + 2
so 5 + logistics that is three this
who gives us eight sports n 4 is already
in open and the in this case
logistics predictions but the function
of evaluations f
associated with number 4 that is already present
in open in lower value so to
because of that we're not going to added m 4 nor
in open nor in close on
following alliterations and 4 will generate
his child who is m6 the path that has
led to m4 pass him by m 3 years 84 so
we act of n2
plus one adds to that now the
end of path level which is 4 us
that gives us the m6 gie who is going to be
of 7
we added on him ristic which is of zero
since had destination logistic and
to 0 and that gives us a value for m6
in their f1 based
of seven-year assessments the association
the parent who the generic and the more we have
took a 4th we add it to claude after
have treated it next iteration
well we see that it is not appropriate to
go out who's the first of open donkey
clues lies to have one lies at
to be a shrapnel so golden if it would be
true hole and so we can stand out the
path that led to m6 going back to
from parents so m6 would have been
reached from m 4 n 4 was
reached from n 3 and n 3 was
reached from 1 0 so it gives
the path n 01 n3m cap and n 6 and that
this is the solution will turn so part to
star
there are other algorithms of
search there stay there is the algorithm
drop research that still makes
much more general research
heuristic
it's a variant everything is actually done
can take any form
we can say that to star is a
special case of best research
but we dream of hate that breaks down
in the sum of j2m and h2 helps young people
it's the stroke to the bullring to buy
a double blow of hand until the beginning
our tourists hic for the moment
until the beginning we also have another
variant which is the gray said drop
research
it is also a best research but
who is voracious and to say that they are
base for exploration only on
the rustic
so it misses the part if more gidel
in that if we are not guaranteed to
find a path that is optimal
unlike stars as we see
when we talk about properties but
it's an algorithm that sometimes work
in practice
so here's an example precisely or at
the star who would return a path
optimal and credit decline research
gives different results
so imagine we have a grid here where
each intersection corresponds to a
it's rumors it would be a wall so
after
they wished to leave hesse and
let's imagine we've got
some roads where is so stopped
between the draws they are blocked
well in that if we did a
solution by willi betz spurs on the
way that would be returned would be the
way here like that these paths light has
longer
our path that the optimal path that
would go under the bar
like that and to etoy would return to him
way there they do not have each other
and finally if it tempts you to see
stars is that other algorithms
from research into action you have a link
here for an online demo where you
can do tests with the
different algorithms for
labyrinths must go from one point to
at a point b
so I encourage you to go play
with this demo there on the web